spiraling horrors a gender-bent riff on
shakespeare and a whole series about
camping here's a few upcoming titles
that anime fans are looking forward to
in 2022
anime and horror fans got some very
welcome news in october 2019 when adult
swim announced it was turning junji
ito's terrifying masterpiece uzumaki
into a four-part mini-series the beloved
late 90s manga received a live-action
adaptation in 2000 that got mixed
reviews but if anyone can pull off an
animated take on ito's supernatural tale
it's hiroshi nakahama
nagahama best known for turning the
trippy horror manga mushishi into a
highly rated hit has big plans for
uzumaki in the first teaser for the show
nagahama stated his artistic vision i
wanted to make something that scares
people and makes them laugh and that
they'll watch over and over that's the
kind of work i want this to be
nagahama's promises got fans of ido's
manga excited but the original 2020
release date came and went without a
premiere in 2021 adult swim confirmed
that uzumaki was still in progress and
would drop the following year nagahama
told fans i feel truly apologetic for
the delay and ask for your patience just
a little more uzumaki which translates
to spiral takes place in a small
japanese town where a supernatural curse
is wreaking havoc production ig the
studio responsible for ghost in the
shell has been making strong efforts to
adapt ito's art style to the screen as
faithfully as possible
funimation teamed up with fox to release
2018's dragon ball super broly in
theaters across 18 different countries
and it proved to be a wise move the film
raked in over 115 million dollars at the
worldwide box office and earned rave
reviews from critics becoming a hit even
with viewers unfamiliar with the
franchise there has been a renewed
interest in all things dragon ball since
the sequel series dragon ball super
began airing in 2015 and the fan base is
now bigger than ever fans who grew up
watching the original 80s anime are now
sharing it with their children creating
what funimation's mitchell burger calls
quote multi-generational appeal this was
reflected in the rapturous response to
dragon ball super broly which gave the
titular saiyan a new and improved origin
story it was so well received in fact
that series creator akira toriyama
confirmed that a new film dragon ball
super superhero was in the pipeline for
2022 it's about time
toriyama hyped up the film on the
official dragon ball website writing
just like the previous movie i'm heavily
leading the story and dialogue
production i really shouldn't talk too
much about the plot yet but be prepared
for some extreme and entertaining bouts
which may feature an unexpected
character the film's title and updated
character designs were revealed at
comic-con at home 2021.
what's cooler than a guy with a chainsaw
a guy who is a chainsaw tatsuki
fujimoto's action fantasy chainsaw man
made waves when it hit shelves in
december 2018. mappa the studio behind
dora hiduro and jujutsu kaizen was quick
to take on the challenge of adapting the
high octane manga denji is a devil
hunter buried in debt barely scraping by
with his devil dog fuchita when a job
gone wrong ends with the yakuza
literally backstabbing him genji makes a
deal with pogita that allows him to be
reborn as a human devil hybrid by
pulling the cord on his chest deji can
become the chainsaw devil a monster with
multiple chainsaws emerging from his
head and arms known for its brutal
fights and dark humor the chainsaw man
manga won the 2020 shogakucan award for
best shonen while an exact release date
has yet to be determined a recent
trailer confirms that fans can expect to
see the bloody affair on the small
screen in 2022
the hit 2020 anime moriarty the patriot
offered a new take on a classic literary
character and another radically
different version of a famous villain is
slated to hit the small screen in 2022
only this time it's one that actually
existed
ayakano's manga series requiem for the
rose king follows a gender fluid version
of richard iii one of the most hated
monarchs in history the show takes place
in the period known as the war of the
roses a 30-year conflict between the
noble houses of york and lancaster when
the story begins richard's father is
closing in on the throne but it's not to
be the duke of york has the crown and
his life snatched away before he can
claim it the loss of his father hits
richard hard the bloody conflict rages
on however and with his beloved dad now
gone richard's thoughts turned to
revenge and ultimately the throne
loosely based on the classic shakespeare
play richard iii the manga debuted in
monthly princess magazine in 2013 and is
still going strong today known for being
full of unexpected twists and turns
requiem of the rose king will no doubt
make for a fascinating anime series when
it drops in january 2022
the rising of the shield hero was one of
the most popular anime of 2019 but it
was also one of the most controversial
on paper it's just a standard isekai a
fantasy subgenre in which the
protagonist is suddenly transported to a
strange new world it's difficult for
nuisakai shows to stand out from the
incredibly large crowd but the rising of
the shield hero managed to do so in an
incredibly bold and risky way after
arriving in his fantasy world the
protagonist is falsely accused of sexual
assault socially ineptotaku naofumi
watani is one of four regular people
summoned to the kingdom of melromark to
save it from impending doom dubbed the
four cardinal heroes each receives a
legendary weapon to help them in their
quest now fumi's weapon being a shield
when his training partner betrays him
with a treacherous lie now fumi becomes
an outcast setting out to combat the
waves of calamity on his own some people
took issue with the show's use of a
sexual assault accusation as a plot
device but fans have been clamoring for
a second season ever since the first one
wrapped
the fact that a couple of cuckoos has
become one of the most anticipated anime
of 2022 is quite remarkable considering
how new the manga that it's based on is
written and illustrated by miki
yoshikawa a couple of cuckoos is massive
in japan two volumes of the cutesy
romcom were sold every second during the
height of its popularity and fans can't
wait to see how director yoshiyuki
shirahara handles the story as the
teaser trailer for the show reveals a
couple of cuckoo's is a love story about
a shy boy and an internet famous girl
introverted high school student nagi
umino is on the way to meet his
biological parents for the first time
when he encounters erica amano a social
media star trying to escape an arranged
marriage she proposes that nagi become
her fake boyfriend so she doesn't have
to go through with it and he reluctantly
agrees they soon discover that nagi is
actually her intended husband after all
they were accidentally switched as
babies and the parents believe a wedding
is the best way they can be a proper
family unfortunately for them nagi has
his eye on someone else and chaos ensues
another show that was pushed back to
2022 because of the coronavirus pandemic
spriggan is collaboration between
netflix and david production for those
unfamiliar with the title spriggan is a
shonen sci-fi manga that ran from 1989
to 1986 and got a movie adaptation in
1998. spriggan takes place in an
alternate reality version of the cold
war in which mankind has discovered the
existence of advanced tech hidden by an
ancient civilization making sure these
gadgets don't fall into the wrong hands
is you ominae a member of an elite unit
that takes on militias and assorted bad
guys with ulterior motives netflix has
already dropped a couple of teaser
trailers for spriggan and they look
great david production knows all about
flamboyance this is the studio behind
jojo's bizarre adventure after all but
they're wisely keeping things sleek and
simple with this particular project
hiroshi kobayashi who has directed
episodes of kizu naiver and tiger and
bunny is overseeing the action
well you can color me impressed
at a glance made in abyss looks like the
kind of show you could comfortably watch
with children but the 2017 adventure
series is far from a family-friendly
affair based on akihito takushi's manga
series of the same name made in abyss
follows an orphan girl named rico who
lives in a town built around a giant
gaping hole referred to as you guessed
it the abyss all manner of strange
artifacts and creatures are said to be
found inside though few are brave enough
to explore its depths those who enter
the hole are known as cave raiders one
of whom was rico's mother although she
seemingly vanished during an expedition
it turns out she may not be gone after
all when rico finds a message from her
mother urging her to meet her in the
abyss she decides that it's time to
explore it for herself with the help of
a new robot friend
season two of made in abyss was
announced in 2019 and a film entitled
dawn of the deep soul dropped the
following year the story is set to
continue in 2022 when the second season
officially titled made in abyss the sun
blazes upon the golden city will come to
air plot details are being kept mostly
under wraps for now but at least one
previously unseen character will appear
manga readers will no doubt recognize
the fluffy white arms of faputa princess
of the naharati
the global phenomenon that was the
attack on titan manga came to an end
when the final chapter shipped in
basatsu shonen magazine in summer 2021
for anime viewers however the journey
doesn't reach its conclusion until 2022
when the second part of the fourth and
final season is set to air attack on
titan's fans became worried when it was
revealed that wit studio would no longer
produce the show after season 3 but mapa
stepped in and exceeded expectations
season 3 of attack on titan ended on a
rare high note for our heroes who got to
see the ocean for the first time but
things were far from rosy when we caught
up with him in attack on titan the final
season part 1. there's a four-year time
jump between the seasons and protagonist
aaron yeager isn't the same man he once
was noticeably older the veteran of the
survey corps has been worn down by the
rigors of war as have his comrades
there's trouble with the country across
the sea marley is at war with the
aldians the descendants of the first
titan aaron also has an old acquaintance
to worry about the part one finale ended
just as he was about to face former
friend reiner braun in battle attack on
titan the final season part 2 will begin
on january 9th 2022
a live action movie adaptation of the
original anime series tiger and bunny
was announced in 2015 with ron howard
attached as a producer despite the fact
that superhero movies have only grown in
popularity there's been little movement
since however fans of tiger and bunny
need not despair their decade long wait
for a second season of the original show
is soon to become a reality sunrise the
studio behind the original tiger and
bunny has confirmed that the highly
anticipated follow-up season entitled
tiger and bunny 2 will come to air at
some point in 2022 tiger and bunny takes
place in a far future city called
sternbuild which is rife with both crime
and superheroes wearing costumes
plastered in sponsors the vigilantes of
sternbuild take part in a show called
hero tv competing against each other by
earning points for every crime they stop
whoever earns the most points is crowned
the king of heroes but not all of them
care about fame and prestige we follow
veteran superhero kotetsu wild tiger
kabaragi and his rookie partner barnby
bunny brooks jr two men who have very
different opinions about what it means
to be a hero
influential 80s anime captain tsubasa
got a brand new season in 2018
reigniting interest in soccer shows in
2022 another fictional japanese player
will make the leap from the pages of his
manga to the small screen ali ashito the
protagonist of yugo kobayashi's aoashi
aoi has plenty of raw talent but needs
some work if he's going to make it all
the way to the jailey japan's premier
soccer division luckily coach tatsuya
fukuda is willing to put the work in
after recognizing his potential the
former pro invites ali to a training
camp for tokyo city's aspirin fc's youth
team like all the other animated soccer
stars that came before him aoi
revolutionizes the sport in japan but
what makes aoashi different is that it's
relatively new and therefore much in
tune with the modern game the action in
captain tsubasa is often so exaggerated
that it barely resembles real soccer but
she takes the sport seriously with
characters learning formations and
executing plays that you would see in an
actual real life game it's the manga
that soccer fans have been waiting for
and the anime adaptation is dropping at
the perfect time it's scheduled for
release during the spring 2022 season
meaning it will be on air in the run-up
to the fifa world cup
from calligraphy to mineralogy to
fishing and ballroom dancing there's an
anime for just about every hobby based
on the slice of life manga of the same
name laid back camp caters to lovers of
camping following a group of friends who
traveled to different sites across japan
it's a delightfully simple story that
made for a charming anime when studio c
station adapted it for the small screen
in 2018 there's also a live action tv
remake for fans to check out but what
they really want is more anime and
that's exactly what they're getting in
2022 as the promotional poster reveals
the laid-back campgrounds are returning
for an anime movie along with the
creators that made the anime series such
a success screenwriters jintanaka and
mitsumi ido are back as is director
yoshiaki kyogoku whose work on laid back
camp earned him an award at the tokyo
anime film festival kyogoku told anime
news network i like to think that the
award went to the show and not to me
while the show is good it's not mine it
was all the staff's hard work that made
it possible i would like to think that
the award came to me as a representative
of the show and not me personally check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite anime are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you